the hunt for Earth 2.0 is still on we've
examined intense Red Dwarf
systems massive super
Earths and alien
exomoons but so far there's no place
like
home there are all these criteria we
have to tick off a sunlike
star an orbit that puts it at about the
right temperature a solid surface
something that could retain an
atmosphere but a planet that appears
earthlike on the outside may not be
earthlike on the
inside one of the things that makes our
world so unique is its plate tectonics
and that actually regulates our
climate the earth's climate depends on
cycles of materials like carbon dioxide
and
water molecules move between the Earth's
molten interior and the surface through
active plate tectonics and volcanic
eruptions these Cycles help to regulate
the temperature and composition of the
Earth's
atmosphere if we were to find another
earthlike planet out there and it had
geologic activity that means that at
least it has the means to to sustain the
the carbon cycle and all of these
natural phenomenon that makes this
planet habitable and and
[Music]
sustainable how can we know what's
happening inside a
planet a clue can be found in vast
ranges across our
world
[Music]
mountains
these topographical features are an
indicator that the planet is alive and
there is still processes happening
underneath its
surface mountain ranges are created when
a planet's tectonic plates
collide and even though exoplanets are
light years away astronomers could work
out whether their surfaces are smooth
were covered in
Peaks those mountain ranges are poking
out and depending on which rotation the
planet is in the planet will appear very
slightly bigger or very slightly smaller
depending on the silhouette which is
being
[Music]
cast these tiny changes in light could
be the sign that an exoplanet is healthy
and
active
but we can only use this method when a
planet is in front of its
star what if astronomers could use
Starlight itself to determine the
geology of a
planet we think that planets form at
roughly the same sort of time that stars
form and they all form from this same
giant cloud of
material and so if you measure the
composition of a star then it seems
reasonable to take those values and
assume they're somewhat similar for the
planets as
well astronomers can work out what
chemical elements are present in the
Star by splitting its light into
different
wavelengths and any planets around that
star will have a similar chemical
composition composition is actually a
really important part of whether or not
it's actually going to be habitable um
the composition really is its
[Music]
geology Rocky exoplanets are all made
from the same basic
ingredients chemical elements Like
Oxygen silicon and
aluminum change the balance of
ingredients and you get very different
planets if we have some idea of the the
composition of a rocky planet we can
actually use that to give us Clues as to
whether a world has or doesn't have
plate
tectonics new Research indicates that
exoplanets with too much silicon and
sodium form different types of rock than
those on
Earth creating rigid planets where plate
tectonics stall and carbon dioxide
builds up with devastating
consequences without active iology we
end up with maybe a venian
atmosphere that means there's a runaway
greenhouse effect it's gotten hotter and
hotter gases are baked out of the Rocks
there's no way to actually rain them
back out not a good place for life at
[Music]
all at worse the planet becomes a
pressure cooker waiting to
explode if we change the composition of
a planet it affects its tectonic system
that entirely changes how a planet loses
Heat and the heat builds up and builds
up and builds up and then maybe there's
a catastrophic overturn of the
[Music]
crust the solid crust of the planet
collapses oceans of lava Bubble Up and a
greenhouse atmosphere boils the surface
a violent end to a potential new
home clearly you need to know about the
composition of those planets before you
can start making statements about how
habitable those worlds truly
are but there's something else that a
planet needs to be earthlike an
invisible shield that protects it from
the dangers of space
providing warmth and life-giving water
an
atmosphere the hunt for Earth 2.0 has
turned up plenty of
planets but for a planet to be like
Earth it has to check a lot of
boxes if you're really looking for Earth
2.0 then you're going to have to find a
Planet that's the same mass and size as
Earth orbiting a sunlike star at about
the same distance with a similar
atmosphere and a lot of surface water
that's in liquid form good
luck and on the list of requirements an
exoplanet's atmosphere is
critical it protects the planet from
huge temperature swings protects the
planet from small asteroid impacts it
protects the planet from dangerous
radiation from space and from the Star
it is almost literally a shield around
the planet protecting us from outer
space but it also has to be the right
kind of
atmosphere get it wrong and a planet can
have crushing boiling conditions on the
surface look at our own solar system the
Sun's habitable zone includes three
different planets Venus Venus Earth and
Mars but Mars has a thin atmosphere and
is too cold Venus has too thick of an
atmosphere and it's too hot we're the
only planet that happens to be just
right so far astronomers have mostly had
to guess if these exoplanets have
atmospheres but now we're looking for
them
directly searching for earthlike
atmospheres around earthlike
planets this is incredibly hard to do so
in order to to look at the details of
these atmospheres and the glare of the
star requires incredibly precise
technology and precise
measurements astronomers detect
atmospheres by watching a planet pass in
front of the
star a small fraction of of light shines
around the edge of the planet and
through the
atmosphere where molecules like water
hydrogen and carbon dioxide absorb
particular wavelengths of light from the
Star if we can see the light of the star
shining through around the planet we can
maybe deduce some information about does
it have an atmosphere what are the
properties of that atmosphere how hot is
it what's it made out of that That's How
we'll be able to determine if things in
the atmosphere might indicate that the
surface is hospitable to
life so far we haven't seen any
exoplanets with atmospheres that we
could live
in but that's about to
change